Video games provide a fun escape from reality. Although they are often depicted with violence,
Lazy and time consuming by some. The debate raged for years - so there is no
Positive effects? Can video games actually make you smarter?
Before we precede events, it is important to note that much of anything is bad - even
broccoli. Doses seriously, too high broccoli can actually be toxic. Heck even
Water toxicity exists. So if you binge and do nothing but play video games, risk
Perhaps outweigh any benefits. In fact, we have a full video dedicated to what would
Happens if you stop going outside, the negative effects of the session - the link at
Describe!
As I have said, many studies actually have increases shown in post cognitive function
Play video games. One study in particular was the participants play Super Mario 64 for 30
Minutes per day more than 2 months. After that, the brains of these participants witnessed an increase
Of the gray matter in areas associated with memory, strategic planning, and fine motor skills
From my hands, compared with those who have not played. This is particularly encouraging
The results of mental disorders that cause these brain regions to shrink. Using video games
As a treatment.
Surprisingly, action games can also increase attention to detail in individuals. take
Look at the following words on the screen, and scream what color the floor is as fast
you may! So: green, blue, orange. Ok, now try a little faster without me. We continue,
It becomes more difficult because there is a conflict between the same word and her
the color. Chances are, if you play more than 5-10 hours of work games per week, you
Able to solve these problems much more quickly. This is because the brain is actually more
Efficiency in areas associated with interest.
Of course, video games can also be incredibly educational! And while it may not be playing
Some of your favorite games for this purpose, there are many certain games that are used
As effective educational tools for young and old.
They may even help children with dyslexia read more effectively. In a small study, Dilixia
Children who played regular video games ended up reading faster and more accurately - once
Again related to improving attention skills. Improvements at the same time, other studies have found
In sight. They can only see smaller details more clearly, such as small writing, however
They have an easier time separating gray levels. The games were a very practiced work
58% are better at recognizing the nuances in contrast. Which is important because that is
One of the first things to reduce with age.
Even in older people, improved memory and concentration are seen. More importantly, specially designed
The brain has been teasing video games to slow the aging process of the brain by
Up to seven years. This is because it is ideologically complex and requires mental energy!
I think you're able to track what's in front of your eyes? Keep an eye on
The blue circle is here. Eventually they will turn yellow like all the others. I'll point out then
To a circle, you tell me if it was originally blue. If you know this ball was not blue, then
I was a human being. But allows make it difficult. Staring in the middle
The screen can help to track blue circles. Was this blue circle originally?
If you say no, you're right. Again, but with 5 blue circles. This was originally one
Blue? Yes - it was. As it turns out, the average person can track about 3-4 things, while
An experienced work gamer can follow around 6-7.
Finally, with the continuing technology to transform medicine, surgical operations are completed with
Introducing cameras and remote control tools. These operations are very clear
Similarity to video games, with screen and control of the device. Not surprisingly, young people
Doctors with previous exposure to video games display fewer errors and complete faster than
Without those.
Of course, all these skills are only useful if you use them; that can not be if all
To do is to play video games. So enjoy your down time and relax with the games in moderation,
But get out there and keep your life diverse as well. Because this is the way you'll win in to
Game of Life.
Got the urgent question you want to answer? Ask them in comments or on Facebook and
Twitter. And if you want to take the lead at home on the next episode ideas behind the scenes,
Check out Personal Instagram and Twitter handles. And subscribe for more weekly science
Video tapes.